I got run over by civilians with the bad
stuff Ghost Recon especially good here
we go let's get stealthy oh my god
all I go to run out as any I'll go to
putting up a notable drill this get up
good don't we go with it
Oh God
oh god I'm still going i don't know how
to spell with your pain no fake
yeah fell for a long way we think you're
crazy no no mr. well ha ha I mean I mean
I'm good I'm good
motorbike
I'm good
other rebel some gay rights activists
something haha do you mean now okay plan
yeah I think you're right i mean way to
go guys it's so colorful not just its
legs up into yeah showing the nicholas
make sense oh yeah but little bit sleepy
Sebastian would you like a slip that's
good oh hahaha down down that takes a
lot under we look at this oh it's the
Greg's message but not so civilian still
cut this [ __ ] the Saudi a two in one
shot hahaha okay forget it up
and market Dolan covenant
I didn't look I just crossed oh yeah get
more than just dead Oh hold it him hey
who's just stolen kisses ish it's just
the tip yeah oh cool oh alright yeah cuz
one motorbike at the front Oh pick me up
I'm standing the chest listen says I
must do a lot of squats
there's a finance hey look up this week
say that haha to be super civilian style
cheating and then go absolutely mowed
down by you gauge a game destroying the
stocks will bring training my problems
hang on I'll Drive buttons what are you
doing in the back of that car there's no
driver you just hit in the boot oh good
we're gonna get he's popping episode of
terrified like this gig oh wow the
cornering of this thing is absolutely
[ __ ] this rotation is it's just thank
you thank you no one can know how to get
to come with us what's going on
it's usually a lot of smoke pouring out
in front of it so I don't know why
there's our partner okay we're getting
into the car we gonna get in the truck
might have to take two cars yeah with a
2 cups I'll take a terrific little day
and think I don't want to get it man
don't take the thing
you guys take this to court I've got the
inner you guys accrued there was thus
picked up we complete camo I'm just
gonna plant sticking out of the service
vehicle wrestle yeah she's gonna breach
here I'm good oh we're gonna move away
down there all right thank choked up oh
we landed it we landed it it's fine good
that's terrifying I feel like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] oh duh he knew this was coming
jumped out of the plane he knew it was
coming 52 the plane good I jumped out of
a helicopter I was just a perishable and
all the way yo man who business all
shocked me out of the year all the fun
oh oh my gosh you're driving a tank yes
I want to play gonna oh yeah i don't
know why i'm just using all this bull
and you stood together girl haha run a
mother all right go away hahahaha boys I
hate it do we get you all right oh
you're in a good gazonga so this is how
we still write this is what ghost recon
to that and it ain't going like faster
than most cars and drive train run in
there what they couldn't even say very
much better I collects over here in
sponge is just hang it up button takes
on the boot again but only that's cool
oh I guess I drivers up this I could use
one of those chips my soldiers thank you
this is a little bit further south than
usual to whatever drink at the bar and
projects moving to get in this notebook
why after we call Santa Muerte is it
dark include relatively getting in the
back there's a pre presentation of death
and the ball thanks
[Music]
yes I saw a house driving a failure
thriller okay Wow guys I'm still a now
the car is undriveable odds that a
blockage hold for you you're a mess ok
so i can get into it
um you killed one thing anything about
you if you gave me a check oh oh oh come
on in the plane how do we failed oh god
get out of my get away from the plate Oh